let's go next to our caller from the 845
area code who's calling today from eight
four five
hey David my name is Johnny
I'm calling from Carmel New York hey
Johnny what's going on I was just
wondering today so everyone knows
basically your take on our prospects for
getting rid of Mitch McConnell in the
Senate in 2020 yeah and much as I hope
you're wrong I kind of do agree that it
is not going to be easy to get rid of
him and he's probably still going to be
there yep
I'm just wondering what your take is on
Bernie's strategy of campaigning in
states where senators basically won't do
what he wants and hopefully rallying the
people to his side so sorry you're
saying senators won't do what he wants
in the sense that they're Republicans is
what you mean well yeah he's mentioned
it about Joe Manchin as well so it's not
just Republicans but like with his uh I
don't know if you knew this baby Bernie
recently took a trip to Kentucky yes I
said he was basically campaigning
against Mitch McConnell and he's
basically said that when he's president
he will be doing this a lot more often I
think it's great idea bondage but
Bernie's savvy because when you go to a
place like Kentucky especially during
the primary you're campaigning for
yourself for the primary you are
campaigning in a sense for Amy McGrath
who's running against Mitch McConnell
you're you're accomplishing a number of
different things you're talking directly
at least potentially to more red state
voters and Elizabeth Warren has done
really well going into red states and
talking to Trump supporters and and just
talking sense into thousands and
thousands of them at all of these
different town halls that she does so I
like the strategy I don't think he's
losing anything by doing it and as long
as he's not only doing that and ignoring
for example strategically important
states early in the primary I guess are
you concerned about the strategy in some
ways there's something about it that
worries you know actually I think it's a
great thing personally um he he's got
this great image of just like being
willing to talk to anyone what was like
during his uh his Fox News interview
when young people were criticizing him
for doing that as well but I really was
just wondering do you actually think
that if
Burnie ends up becoming the president
and we don't take back the Senate Mitch
McConnell still the majority leader do
you think a strategy like that would
actually have any effect on Mitch
McConnell bringing things up for a vote
a vote or even like switching votes over
it's possible I mean if so okay to play
out your scenario if Bernie becomes
president and the Democrats extend or at
least keep their lead their control of
the house but don't take over the Senate
which is the most likely scenario in the
Senate in 2020 I just don't see the math
for Democrats to take it over the
scenario that might make Mitch McConnell
stop the obstruction is if he
understands that with a popular
Democratic president campaigning against
him in Kentucky he may actually lose
however understand that they're only up
for re-election every six years which
means if McConnell survives 2020 that
gets him to 2026 I think he'll be close
to 90 years old at that point I don't
know if he must be between 84 and 88 at
this point in time so it's also possible
that he just doesn't care he is going to
obstruct to the very last day knowing
that his 2020 reelection would be the
last one he's hoping for anyway and it's
hard to have leverage over someone like
that yeah that's really my main concern
with it thanks for taking my call David
I appreciate it all right Johnny from
New York I appreciate it great to hear
from you